para falar sobre singularidade
tecnológica
eu vou lembrar um pouco da minha
não faz muito tempo lá em cambuquira a
poucos km 129 daqui eu era um garoto que
como todos os garotos adoravam assistir
televisão
tinha bastante televisão gostar muito de
seriados como até hoje é muita gente a
grande maioria também adora assistir
seriados séries e uma das séries que eu
gostava muito e que era também
ainda bem né uma das que fazia mais
sucesso na época chamava-se o homem de
seis milhões de dólares
é a história apontava a história que é
contada nessa série era de spin off em
um coronel da aeronáutica americano que
sofre um acidente num avião e ele veste
um membro perna braço perde à vista e
isso lá nos anos 70 ele é reconstruído
através de próteses usando tecnologia
que na época era apenas ficção assim
como a série a proposta da da série era
ser uma série de ficção entretenimento e
assim que ela era vista nós crianças
adultos e as era muito popular
ela passava no horário nobre da
televisão e mail hits para o ator
principal que seria uma ideia era casado
com a farra falsa e os dois eram mais ou
menos como brad pitt e angelina jolie
hoje em dia o casal mais falado na mídia
celebridades mais comentadas exatamente
por causa do sucesso das panteras da
forma falsa e do homem de seis milhões
de dólares em média
naquele momento a gente enxergava essa
história de um homem biônico que ela é o
nome que foi usado aqui no brasil o
homem de seis milhões de dólares é o
homem biônico homem que utilizava
prótese robotizados enxergava isso
apenas exclusivamente como ficção é é um
jornal inglês
recentemente fez uma análise consultou o
preço de mercado quanto custariam essas
próteses hoje
dia para substituir os membros se alguém
sofresse um acidente semelhante e
precisa se colocar as mesmas próteses
que o steel azin e chegou a essa cifra
600 mil dólares ou seja o homem de seis
milhões de dólares dos anos 70 em 2014
sairia por uma pechincha apenas 10% do
seu custo porque isso é esse exemplo eu
vou utilizar pra mostrar pra vocês é um
pouco mais sobre a questão da
singularidade e que está diretamente
relacionada com a evolução e com a
rapidez da evolução da tecnologia a
evolução da ciência da tecnologia
associada à nossa saúde e e aos humanos
a nós mesmos com uma tecnologia tem é
rapidamente evoluído para solucionar os
nossos problemas de diversos tipos
normalmente quando a gente fala em
tecnologia se pensa em aplicação de
tecnologia na indústria nas empresas
comércio serviço mas existe muita
tecnologia
obviamente sendo aplicada na medicina na
genética a melhoria por exemplo é da
agricultura e essa tecnologia tem tido
os autos não têm tido passos de evolução
e esses autos eles direcionam para um
momento no futuro que esse cara
rancoroso
ele prevê que seria em 2045 o momento da
singularidade é o caso do noel quem
inventou o termo ou quem criou é ele é
uma das pessoas mas é uma das mais
reconhecidas e comentadas citadas dessa
área tanto que hoje mesmo evento ted
vocês ainda vão ouvir falar sobre a
singularidade sobre o caso bruno o
robert half provavelmente vão ainda
falar sobre a singularidade porque é um
tema que tem atraído a atenção de muita
gente e por isso mesmo é eu vou tentar
explicar um pouco melhor as questões da
singularidade e assim
ficar porque eu acredito e que nós
estamos indo nesse caminho
caso eu ele é um inventor criou diversos
dispositivos eletrônicos
ele é autor de diversos livros é um
empreendedor diversos equipamentos que
ele criou ele montou empresas para
fabricar esses equipamentos os teclados
caso é ele é o futurólogo que
normalmente dentro da área de ciência
quando você fala em futurologia
normalmente causa alguns calafrios as
pessoas começam não futurólogos então
ele tem carta de tarô para ver o futuro
na verdade ele usou dados científicos
pra medir tendências e tentar
identificar se realmente não estamos
caminhando para essa singularidade é ele
também o rapper porque ele tenta e ele
acredita que é possível hackear não só a
doer não software mas é possível hackear
os humanos é possível nos hackear a
definição de singularidade está no livro
dele de 2008 chamada singularidade está
próxima e a idéia de maneira mais
simplificada e eu até vou tentar mostrar
mais em matéria de exemplos é de que num
determinado momento será impossível
distinguir homem de máquina ou homem de
tecnologia para isso nós temos que
evoluir evoluir muito em diversas áreas
área genética por exemplo a área de
nanotecnologia área de robótica e
logicamente essa essas áreas todas têm
evoluído bastante a gente se surpreende
todos os dias com os novos produtos e
lançamentos e pesquisas é que aparecem é
sobre essas áreas é a genética por
exemplo não é uma área muito popular
ainda não se fala tanto na imprensa
convencional só nas publicações
específicas especializadas mas a
genética ela tem reduzido custo por
exemplo o seqüenciamento do dna é de
maneira exponencial essa esse gráfico
mostra exponencialmente a queda do custo
do sequenciamento genético e porque isso
é importante se eu quero rap alguma
coisa tem que conhecer se eu quero aqui
a software tem
conhecer muito de software eu quero aqui
a hardware sem conhecer muitos
eletrônica
se eu quero hackear o ser humano eu
tenho que conhecer o elemento os
elementos que compõem o ser humano
então é essencial que eu conheça o dna
que eu conheça genética para que eu
possa a partir daí manipular essa
própria genética não só o custo mas
também a quantidade de dados tem sido
gerada é sobre dna tem crescido
exponencialmente e é importante reparar
é que eu tenho falado exponencialmente
diferentemente de um crescimento linear
que é de um mais um é dois mais um e
três mais um é 4
nós estamos falando de algo que cresce
12 22 32 43 2 e 8 meses 2 16
então o crescimento exponencial ele
tende a chegar no momento chamado joelho
da curva onde as coisas se tornam
exclusivas e aí é por isso mesmo é nós
estamos talvez nos aproximando os tenha
estejamos neste momento
nesse meio da curva que vai nos levar ao
momento da singularidade
nós podemos mesmo no saque a precisa se
mais algumas nós já estamos nos achando
na verdade pra melhorar ou para poder
aprimorar o aumentar a nossa capacidade
de armas vamos precisar ainda evoluir em
algumas tecnologias
uma delas a nanotecnologia que também
tem evoluído rapidamente no gráfico
mostra que por exemplo a redução do
tamanho dos dispositivos mecânicos ao
longo dos tempos do tempo é e com essas
possibilidades junto com o conhecimento
nem de dna a possibilidade de criar nos
equipamentos positivos minúsculos esses
dispositivos sendo robôs capazes de
fazer atividades programadas
nós podemos de repente criar substitutos
para não só órgãos membros nós tenham
temos o nosso corpo mas até glóbulos por
exemplo na não na nano robótica por
exemplo nós poderíamos criar
dispositivos minúsculos capazes de fazer
atividades que as células do nosso corpo
não consegue fazer
isso são pesquisas estão em avançado que
o ritmo acelerado que nós temos visto
nessas áreas é não há é não há uma
obstáculo que impeça que isso aconteça
um obstáculo ainda é o tempo
nós temos também uma evolução e essa é
muito mais fácil de perceber que todos
nós aqui somos usuários consumidores
computadores e aqui eu tenho um exemplo
que o trouxe de uma propaganda de um
computador o computador padrão de 1997
o computador que todo mundo gostaria de
ter naquele momento o preço dele era de
três mil oitocentos e noventa reais
se você pegar uma tabelinha do gpm lá
nos últimos anos você vai perceber que
esse computador hoje custaria 12 mil
setecentos e sessenta reais
então o computador legal hoje né de
acordo com o preço daquela época é se
fossem atualizados os preços ele
chegaria a esse valor é bastante caro
dois mil setecentos e sessenta reais e
com uma capacidade que é praticamente
esse computador seu desce para alguns de
vocês hoje ninguém gostaria de ganhar
esse presente
apesar de no preço ele tem um valor
muito alto a gente atualizar pelo gpm
na verdade a funcionalidade dele é pífia
perto de qualquer computador nós
tenhamos hoje por exemplo há o poder
escutar de computação desse computador
de 1997 é o mesmo ou inferior a um
computador como esse
o rácio pai que custa 25 dólares e hoje
está disponível é para a compra de sua
fala mas que vou fazer com computação
como esse você mesmo disse que se eu
fosse dar um computador você não faria
nada com ele né vocês rejeitariam esse
computador
na verdade um só de si ele tem poucas
funções têm funções mas são poucas as
pessoas criativas podem utilizar os
computadores maneiras criativas
o professor simon cox juntou 64 as
principais 4 mil dólares pegou as peças
de lego do filho dele e montou um
supercomputador
que executa 70 gigaflops 70 bilhões de
operações de ponto flutuante por segundo
bom esse número é meio é distante da
nossa realidade
o anúncio dos nerds só para dar uma
idéia o primeiro supercomputador mais
famoso primeiro supercomputador um raio
banco criado por senhor foi lá em 1986
sabe quantos gigaflops ele conseguia
executar nenhum 160 milhões de flops não
era nenhum gigaflops mas aí
nove anos depois saiu cry 2 estava um
triângulo 9 gigaflops só no começo dos
anos 90 é que um supercomputador chegou
ao poder de computação de executar é 30
gigaflops por aí
e lá no meio dos anos 90 chegou aos 70
gigaflops ou seja há 20 anos atrás você
gasta milhões de dólares para construir
um supercomputador que hoje pode ser
construído com dispositivos disponíveis
no mercado a preço baixo juntando as
peças de lego criatividade
supercomputador pra que eu preciso
estamos falando de evolução da máquina
ao ponto de ela ser indistinguível do
ser humano então obviamente nós vamos
precisar de inteligência artificial não
só membros robôs
nós vamos precisar capacidade e de
inteligência nas máquinas nos
computadores e isso vai acontecer
e pra que isso vai acontecer em diversas
áreas que hoje já fazem uso da
inteligência artificial mas ainda
precisam de mais capacidade
elas ainda não são tão boas quanto
poderiam é teoricamente ela tem um
potencial muito grande mas ainda precisa
avançar na computação precisa se colocar
você criar computadores mais baratos
mais acessíveis com mais capacidade de
processamento para que você consiga
executar criar realmente inteligência
artificial utilizando é esses
computadores e está sendo feito uma
previsão de 1965 feita pelo guarda
humour um dos fundadores da intel
ele disse que em 65 que a cada 18 meses
a capacidade dos computadores e do pará
êêê desde então essa previsão vem se
confirmando
é e alguns números mostram pra gente
aqui mostrando só a diferença é como
esse crescimento disse
a questão de dobrar é um crescimento
exponencial
esse gráfico mostra diferença entre o
crescimento linear e crescimento
exponencial linear com mais um mais um
mais um é o linear 2222 e aqui o joelho
da curva um momento onde as coisas
começam a se tornar explosiva é é a que
o número de transistores por chip
quantidade de transições que tem sido
colocado em cada chip na evolução ao
longo do tempo nos processadores aqui a
capacidade dos supercomputadores
desde que começaram a ser medidas as
capacidades deles indica flops até as
tendências para o futuro sendo que todas
essas linhas
elas têm tendências muito parecidas não
há nada que indique que esse crescimento
chegou ao seu auge o seu apogeu ea
partir dali vai haver um decréscimo
todas essas linhas de crescimento de
capacidade aqui sobre o a velocidade do
clock dos microprocessadores também
tendência de aumento
a capacidade e o custo de armazenamento
de dados magnéticos também numa análise
totalmente é crescente
sem nenhuma amostra de estabilidade ou
decréscimo
então todas essas expectativas de
crescimento elas levam a um mundo onde o
computador passa a ser algo muito mais
normal muito mais comum no nosso dia a
dia ea gente passa a ter o computador
não mais no computador e aí porque nós
precisamos de computadores robótica não
tecnologia genética com toda essa
evolução de todas essas áreas passa se a
ter uma vida onde a gente não percebe
muitas vezes que a gente está lidando
com equipamentos muito sofisticados se
comparados às 20 30 anos atrás esse
presente é um roubo
o aspirador de pó é que muitas vezes as
pessoas não percebem a capacidade
computacional que tem aí nem a nenhum
dos grandes cientistas da área de
computação
lá nos anos 40 e 50 contava alimentando
o computador imaginava que um dia o
computador está embutido dentro de um
aspirador de pó que é um produto objeto
de consumo bastante é difundido e assim
como outros fazem parte do nosso dia a
dia sem que nós percebamos então da
mesma forma que esses objetos
eles vão fazendo parte do nosso dia a
dia é na nossa cozinha na nossa casa
muitas vezes a gente vai se tornando
dependentes de equipamentos de softwares
de smartphones por exemplo que fazem
grande parte das coisas que antes nós
tínhamos que fazer
hoje o smartphone é uma parte da sua
memória
você deixou por conta dele registrar os
números de telefone das pessoas que você
conhece deixou por conta dele anotava os
compromissos da sua agenda é e diversas
outras coisas você não precisa nem de
qual caminho seguir o gps do smartphone
e leva aonde você quer com isso você vai
passando a responsabilidade de diversas
atividades que eram eminentemente
humanas e próprias de você para
dispositivos tecnológicos que passam a
fazer parte natural do nosso dia a dia e
com a evolução toda de todas as
tecnologias
será que nós vamos saber realmente quem
são ciborgues ou que são suportes ou
será que isso vai ser tão natural que
nós vamos simplesmente os achar humanos
melhorados em relação ao que éramos
antes
esse é o momento da singularidade é uma
música de fundo que foi composta para
essa apresentação ela foi composta por
um ex-aluno amigo meu
rafael castro chama-se singularidade
para hélio errei e com ela eu termino a
minha apresentação e espero que tenha a
player esclarecido para você é é um
pouco mais sobre a questão da
singularidade que tenha despertado a sua
curiosidade para conhecer muito mais